[Musique]
bonjour Valérie Boyer bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élus des
Bouches-du-Rhône membre du groupe les
républicains on va bien sûr parler avec
vous Marseille de Marseille du pape de
l'arrivée du pape à Marseille de la
situation au Caraba également dans
quelques instants mais d'abord vous
étiez hier dans l'hémicycle
du roi Charles qu'est-ce que vous avez
ressenti dans ce moment qui est quand
même historique c'est la première fois
qu'un roi s'exprimait dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat c'était une joie un honneur et
puis c'est vrai que c'est la célébration
de la démocratie de la démocratie de la
plus vieille démocratie du monde
à des démocratie les plus peut-être
connues dans le monde que la France
toutes deux avec un régime particulier
mais pour aller droit au but je vais
parvenir sur ce moment historique etc je
dois vous dire que d'une façon globale
compte tenu de la situation
internationale moi j'ai été très déçue
et même amer de voir que deux grands
pays qui siègent au Conseil permanent de
sécurité de l'ONU que sont la France et
l'Angleterre n'est pas eu un seul mot
pour la solution finale je n'emploie pas
ce terme par hasard la solution finale
qui est mise en place par l'Azerbaïdjan
en ce moment à l'égard des Arméniens et
qui n'est rien d'autre que une épuration
ethnique la poursuite du génocide et les
radications de toute une civilisation on
va en parler de ça dont il s'agitation
mais est-ce que ces deux membres du
Conseil de sécurité et au moins un mot
nous avons
fait de politique oui mais là eux
s'exprimer sur ce sujet c'est pas écouté
la situation est tellement grave il a eu
des mots sur l'Ukraine ce qui est normal
aujourd'hui puisque nous sommes engagés
dans ce conflit
vis-à-vis de cette agression totalement
barbare et inutile des Russes pourquoi
ne pas avoir un mot pour pour l'Arménie
qui vit une situation qu'on peut
comparer à l'Ukraine au lieu de mort
génocide de 1915
volonté de disparition les Ukrainiens
disent que c'est encore un génocide qui
se passe les Arméniens savent
parfaitement que 110 ans après le
génocide de 1915 l'histoire se répète et
bégaye donc là je pense que c'est un
devoir d'humanité et quand on fait appel
à la démocratie à l'humanité ne pas
avoir un mot de la France et de
l'Angleterre qui sont quand même deux
phares de la démocratie pour ces pays je
trouve que ils ont raté leur rendez-vous
avec l'histoire on va parler je vous le
disais dans quelques instants de la
situation au Caravage juste un dernier
mot sur ce discours du Rochat c'était
une ode à l'amitié franco-britannique
est-ce que ça visite d'État peut
réchauffer les relations entre la France
et le Royaume-Uni je l'espère parce que
de toute façon tout ce qui a été dit
hier est une évidence
nous avons intérêt aujourd'hui nous
sommes confrontés au défi migratoire
nous partageons ce couloir qui comme la
Méditerranée est aussi un cimetière de
migrants et nous avons
les mêmes défis à relever et je rappelle
quand même que l'Angleterre et la France
étaient les plus grandes armées de
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui c'est la
France et la Pologne donc nous avons
intérêt et puis c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
cette sinistre à faire des des
sous-marins australiens etc bonbons
beaucoup de dossiers donc c'est très
important de réchauffer les relations
mais c'est très important au dire aussi
de dire quelle est la place de la France
de l'Angleterre et de l'Europe des
Européens dans le monde et se taire sur
un conflit comme celui du Karaba je
pense que ça
je veux dire c'est pas quelque chose qui
est
positif pour la place de ces deux grands
pays dans le monde on en parle tout de
suite de ce conflit puisque on l'a
compris évidemment vous suivez de très
près la situation le ok rabat ce
territoire majoritairement peuplé
d'Arméniens qui a subi exclusivement
peuplé d'Arméniens qui a subi il y a
quelques jours une offensive de
l'Azerbaïdjan on va voir les
explications sur ce qui se passe là-bas
d'abord avec Samia de chien
[Musique]
bonjour Samia bonjour Oriane bonjour
Valérie Boyer bonjour Samia des
pourparlet ont commencé hier pour mettre
fin aux affrontements dans le
haut-karaba on va en parler mais d'abord
on a besoin avec vous d'un éclairage sur
les raisons de ce conflit oui le haut
Karaba pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est une région qui appartient
officiellement à l'Azerbaïdjan mais qui
est peuplé d'Arméniens pourquoi en fait
ça remonte à l'époque soviétique
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan étaient
membres de l'URSS et c'est Staline qui a
à l'époque décidé que cet enclave serait
rattachée à l'Azerbaïdjan sauf que les
séparatistes Arméniens n'ont jamais
cessé de réclamer leur rattachement à
l'Arménie et ça a donc provoqué
plusieurs conflits dont le dernier avec
la thème hardi c'est l'Azerbaïdjan qui a
lancé les hostilités une opération
militaire éclair qui a fait au moins 200
morts et 400 blessés en 24 heures
accumuler les séparatistes Arméniens ont
rapidement capituler et ils ont même
accepté de remettre leurs armes c'est
donc une lourde défaite pour Oriane dès
pour parler on commençait hier entre
l'Azerbaïdjan et les séparatistes
Arméniens oui a priori les discussions
se passent plutôt bien l'un des enjeux
des négociations c'est l'ouverture du
corridor de la Chine c'est la seule
route qui relie le haut Karaba à
l'Arménie vous pouvez le voir sur cette
carte mais depuis plusieurs mois
l'Azerbaïdjan a coupé cet axe et ce
blocus il a des conséquences dramatiques
pour les Arméniens du haut Karaba qui se
retrouvent privés de nourriture des sens
de soins l'aide humanitaire est bloquée
l'Arménie dénonce un génocide en cours
et ce n'est pas la seule Valérie Boyer
vous êtes membre du Cercle d'amitié
France harsac hardsac c'est le nom donné
par les Arméniens à cette région du
haut-karaba est-ce que vous avez des
informations sur la situation des civils
qui se trouvent dans cette zone à
l'heure actuelle les informations sont
alarmantes mais elles sont alarmantes
depuis on va dire depuis la guerre de
2020 qui est une guerre totalement
asymétrique qui a été déclenché
uniquement par l'Azerbaïdjan qui a
utilisé des armes non conventionnelles
qui n'a toujours pas rendu des
prisonniers depuis 2020 et qui étaient
en a eu quand il a eu des Arméniens en
cours à massacrer violet torturé de
façon absolument atroce tout ce qu'il
pouvait aujourd'hui vous présenter ça
comme si c'était un conflit non c'est
pas un conflit c'est à dire qu'il y a
120000 Arméniens qui sont emprisonnés
chez eux sur leur terre qui est une
terre arménienne et pas azéri entouré
d'Azerbaïdjanais moi je me suis rendue à
plusieurs reprises et notamment après la
guerre de 2020 puisque je m'y suis
rendue avec une délégation parlementaire
en secret en avril 2021 et le corridor
de la Chine c'est tout petit il y a des
endroits qui sont plus petits que ce
studio et vous voyez les mitraillettes
azerbaïdjanaises qui sont là vous voyez
les soldats Algérie comme je vous vois
aujourd'hui ils ont cette proximité là
qui empêche les Arméniens de se nourrir
de se soigner depuis cette période donc
donc aujourd'hui la situation est
alarmante pourquoi parce que comme les
nazis ont leur temps et j'emploie pas ce
mot par hasard les azerbes aljanais
souhaitent prendre des prisonniers ce
qu'ils appellent des terroristes en fait
c'est pas une opération de guerre comme
si il y avait la guerre ce sont des
personnes qui sont sur armées et qui
s'attaquent à des personnes qui sont
totalement démunies aujourd'hui soit des
civils affamés ou non soignés puisque
vous l'avez dit la l'aide humanitaire
n'a pas pu parvenir Bruno Retailleau
était sur place il y a quelques semaines
avec des recettes avec d'autres élus de
Paris de Marseille de Lyon en fait je
crois que tous les élus français sont
totalement solidaires et l'aide
humanitaire la nourriture les
médicaments les prothèses enfin tout le
matériel médical les Azerbaïdjanais
n'ont pas voulu qu'ils parviennent donc
aujourd'hui la situation est alarmante
quand vous avez un pays une dictature
comme celle d'alliere qui dit qu'elle
veut prendre des terroristes en fait
elle veut prendre des Arméniens pour les
exhiber les torturés et les juger avec
des procès bidons comme ils ont
l'habitude de le faire et donc
aujourd'hui certains soldats russes il y
en a 6 je crois qui sont morts
l'Azerbaïdjan s'est excusé pour les
soldats russes
sont
ont permis à des à des civils à des
femmes à des enfants peut-être à des
personnes âgées de pouvoir prendre
l'avion pour partir en tout cas sur
l'aéroport de Stéphane hacker il y a ces
personnes qui peuvent peut-être se
sauver pour aller en Arménie on s'est
parfaitement que quand les
Azerbaïdjanais vont décider de rentrer
dans ce qu'il reste de
duo Karaba enfin de l'arc Sark
c'est-à-dire c'est Stephen hacker et
quelques petites villes
la situation des civils va être atroce
on va avancer juste un mot parce que ce
territoire il est peuplé d'Arméniens
mais dans le droit international il
appartient bien à l'azerbaïque oui
effectivement
c'est plus complexe que ça effectivement
sur Google
mais il est évident
c'est peuplé d'Arméniens c'est une
république qui avait été autoproclamée
une démocratie
et que aujourd'hui et bien
l'objectif de l'Azerbaïdjan c'est de
faire disparaître et il le disent
chasser les Arméniens comme des chiens
quand on animalise d'autres êtres
humains ou à très bien quel est le sort
qui va leur être réservé et de faire
flotter le drapeau de l'Islam comme l'a
dit à l'if ou Erdogan à sushi on va voir
quelle est la position de la France
Emmanuel Macron a condamné
l'intervention de l'Azerbaïdjan qu'il
juge je cite inacceptable en réaction
l'Azerbaïdjan accuse la France
d'islamophobie une précision est
nécessaire ici l'Azerbaïdjan est
majoritairement peuplé de musulmans
chiites alors que l'Arménie est
essentiellement habitée par des
chrétiens Valérie Boyer la France on l'a
dit elle condamne premier royaume
chrétien du monde elle condamne cette
intervention est-ce que cette
condamnation c'est suffisant pour vous
ou que vous réclamez des sanctions
non c'est insuffisant je me permets de
vous rappeler que au Sénat nous avons
voté une résolution où on demandait
le gel des avoirs et des condamnations
l'azerbes avec Jean non seulement n'est
pas au bord des nations mais reçu
royalement partout dans le monde y
compris toujours partie
des instances européennes vous savez à
des juges et
l'Azerbaïdjan a des ambassades partout
et reçu en grande pompe partout donc
nous nous avions demandé le gel des
avoir de du clan à l'if et de la
dictature azéri des enquêtes sur la
diplomatie du caviar l'Azerbaïdjan est
un des rares États du monde qui
pratiquent la diplomatie de la menace
c'est-à-dire que quand vous vous rendez
en artsac quand vous vous rendiez en
artsac et bien vous étiez personne à
notre gratin c'est à dire sur une liste
noire
et aujourd'hui ça ne suffit pas il faut
demander la protection la protection
pour sauver ce qui peut l'être pour
sauver des femmes des enfants des hommes
la question du gaz ah oui c'est dans ce
genre de conflit il y a des questions
économiques qui jouent ah bah c'est
au-delà de la question économique et
puis nous avons un problème un vrai
problème au sein de l'Union européenne
je pense qu'il faut lui remettre
était un allié surfable et au moment de
au début de la du conflit entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine elle s'est
précipitée à bas coût pour pouvoir
acheter du gaz azerbaïdjanais on s'est
parfaitement que que c'est que cette
énergie azerbaïdjanaise et acheter à la
Russie et revendu puisque on en achète
plus plus de de gaz à l'Azerbaïdjan qui
ne produit donc on sait parfaitement qui
vient de Russie je veux dire ça c'est
une hypocrisie internationale et
d'ailleurs la Russie s'en vente
puisqu'elle n'a jamais eu autant de
liquidité qu'aujourd'hui justement on va
en parler de la Russie parce que on est
en troisième acteur clé dans ce
exactement c'est la Russie Samia oui
tout à fait la dernière guerre qui a eu
lieu dans le haut-karaba qui était en
2020 elle avait pris fin sous médiation
de la Russie et normalement ce sont des
soldats russes de maintien de la paix
qui sont censés assurer la sécurité du
fameux corridor de la Chine dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure sauf que ces
derniers temps elle a réussi elle a été
un petit peu plus concentré sur le
conflit ukrainien en tout cas elle n'a
pas réussi à maintenir ouvert ce
corridor de la Chine cette fois-ci ces
derniers jours Vladimir Poutine a quand
même appelé le président de
l'Azerbaïdjan pour lui demander je cite
de respecter les droits des Arméniens du
haut-karaba est-ce que vous pensez
Valérie Boyer que la Russie veut et peut
garantir la paix dans le haut Karaba
je sais pas je veux il peut j'en sais
strictement rien en tout cas je pense
qu'elle a beaucoup de mal elle ne le
souhaite plus et que maintenant elle
s'est rapprochée de la Turquie et de et
de l'Azerbaïdjan très clairement et que
effectivement qu'elle abandonne qu'elle
a abandonné les Arméniens clairement
c'est une
c'est l'éternel histoire de de cette
zone là aujourd'hui
et que profitant de ce moment où on est
concentré vers l'Ukraine avec d'ailleurs
le soutien de de la Turquie et bien on
laisse les Arméniens à leur triste sort
mais justement aujourd'hui il serait
temps que l'Arménie a demandé hier
d'être sous la protection du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et des casques bleus
ce que je veux vous dire aujourd'hui
et tous ceux qui connaissaient cette
zone et qui s'intéressent à ce conflit
savent parfaitement que ça va pas
s'arrêter au Karaba après il va y avoir
un autre corridor dans un autre endroit
de l'Arménie
l'enjeu est important puisqu'à l'Iran
aussi qui est l'Iran la Turquie la
Russie mais aujourd'hui il y a une
urgence absolue à protéger les civils
ascaryote du de la ressac et l'autre
urgence aussi c'est de faire en sorte
que l'Arménie qui a été attaquée dans
son intégrité territoriale c'est-à-dire
là on est dans un état reconnu par la
communauté internationale qui depuis la
guerre de la dernière guerre de 2020 des
44 jours a été attaquée sur son
territoire que l'Azerbaïdjan ne cesse de
grignoter et aujourd'hui et bien c'est
le sort de l'Arménie même qui est en jeu
donc c'est essentiel et il est temps que
le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU que les
casques bleus interviennent sur cette
zone sinon on verra tous des larmes de
crocodile en disant mon Dieu les pauvres
et c'est la poursuite du génocide de
1915 c'est une évidence
la Turquie la Turquie et l'Azerbaïdjan
ne s'en cache pas le pape qui va arriver
à Marseille cet après-midi a appelé à
faire taire les armes au Carabas est-ce
que vous attendez un message de lui ce
weekend sur ce sujet
je pense qu'on ne peut enfin que le pape
ne peut pas venir à Marseille
moi je serai à la messe Samedi bien sûr
comme des milliers de personnes et plus
peut-être des millions toutes celles qui
qui se joindront
à ce qui va se passer à Marseille pour
prier pour la paix pour prier pour les
personnes qui souffrent pour payer pour
les personnes qui sont déplacées pour
payer pour les migrants mais aussi les
réfugiés et quand on est tous émus par
le sort des migrants qui sont au proies
des trafiquants d'êtres humains je pense
qu'il faut le dire mais je pense qu'on
doit être aussi ému pour ce qui se passe
en Arménie je disais premier royaume
chrétien du monde mais pas seulement un
pays qui qui souffre toujours des traces
du génocide donc on va parler de
l'Arménie n'est pas possible et je me
permets de rajouter une chose mais venir
aussi à Marseille sans parler des
migrants oui mais aussi des personnes
qui reçoivent des migrants et qui
souffrent
merci Samia à tout à l'heure on parlera
des sénatoriales avec vous on continue
évidemment à parler de la venue du pape
à Marseille puisque la question
migratoire sera au coeur du déplacement
du peuple le peuple qui appelle à
l'humanité qui appelle à ne pas rester
indifférent face au sort des migrants en
Méditerranée est-ce que vous entendez ce
message non seulement on l'entend mais
je dois dire que les Européens sont
exemplaires dans cette dans la façon
dont on l'accueille se fait et dont ils
le font
on est quand même face à une situation
qui est absolument inédite où on n'a
jamais eu autant de personnes qui
arrivent sans y être invité sur notre
sort qui ne sont pas des réfugiés
politiques on est bien d'accord qui sont
des personnes qui choisissent de venir
chez nous pour des raisons économiques
Darmanin dit qu'on accueillera pas de
migrantes d'USA est-ce que vous le
soutenez là-dessus parce que c'est pas
contradictoire avec le message
Darmanin s'est très bien qu'on
accueillera des personnes de lampe et
12a puisque de toute façon non moi je
pense qu'il ne faut pas d'accord avec
lui bien sûr que je suis d'accord avec
lui je pense qu'il faut pas tout
confondre il y a les réfugiés politiques
dont
la situation doit être examinée
dans des pays qui ne sont pas des pays
européens et puis il y a ces personnes
qui viennent qui payent des passeurs qui
payent des trafiquants d'êtres humains
pour venir en France en Europe parce
qu'elles savent très bien qu'on ne
repartiront pas parce que l'Europe est
le seul endroit du monde ou quand vous
pénétrez sur son territoire même si vous
n'y êtes pas invité même si vous
pénétrez illégalement même si vous même
si vous commettez des méfaits sur son
territoire vous ne vous ne rentrez pas
chez vous donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné
il y a une souffrance de ces personnes
tout à fait exactes mais moi je n'oublie
pas la souffrance aussi des personnes
qui les accueillent le poids économique
que ça représente pour notre pays on a
parlé de 55 milliards récemment
aujourd'hui la situation
qui n'est
impressionnable sur le plan humain sur
le plan de l'intégration sur le plan de
vous savez il y a pas d'humanité
bien sûr il y a pas d'humanité à
accueillir des personnes qui sont sur
les bretelles d'autoroute sous les ponts
et qui traînent dans les rues ou sous
les portes cochères des immeubles je ne
vois pas où est l'humanité à faire ça
aujourd'hui et puis
je suis surprise qu'on parle pas non
plus de la détresse des gens de
l'amphibouza qui sont admirables et qui
sont je trouve très symboliques de de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en Europe qui
je le rappelle est le seul endroit du
monde c'est pas le seul endroit du monde
où ces personnes pourraient aller mais
elles choisissent de venir chez nous de
cette façon donc je pense que
aujourd'hui
vous savez Jean-Paul II disait que
c'était très important comme la
philosophe Simone Veil d'ailleurs que
ont pu être enraciné et qu'on avait le
droit de l'être aujourd'hui donc je
crois de tous ces débats sont essentiels
et c'est vrai que on aura beaucoup de
prière à faire samedi
alors justement puisque samedi vous
l'avez dit vous serez présents il y a
une polémique sur la venue d'Emmanuel
Macron à cette messe au Vélodrome et
Olivier Marleix par exemple qui est le
patron des députés les républicains il
dit la messe c'est pas un one man show
c'est pas un peu Ning il a tort de
critiquer la présence d'Emmanuel Macron
à cette messe ah non mais il a raison de
dire que la messe n'est ni à one Mansion
que la présence d'Emmanuel Macron j'ai
eu l'immense bonheur de d'être quand
j'étais gamine
au Parc des Princes lorsque Jean-Paul II
est arrivé et c'était une liesse
extraordinaire je m'en souviens encore
pour vous c'est un problème qu'Emmanuel
Macron il y a cette messe non je pense
que c'est franchement c'est sa place
d'abord l'église la messe est ouverte à
tous croyant ou non croyant il accueille
un chef d'État
donc vous avez mon Seigneur Aveline a
une très belle phrase lorsqu'il a
préparé
l'avenue du pape à Marseille c'est vrai
que le pape François avait peut-être une
autre idée sur la façon dont il devait
venir à Marseille mais je crois qu'il
l'a dit
au Saint-Père très sympa vous ne pouvez
pas empêcher les Français de prier avec
vous et voilà je pense que c'est ce qui
va se passer samedi
qui vient à Marseille et pas en France
vous l'entendez comment oui mais quand
il était venu à Strasbourg en pas en
France mais en Europe bah écoutez c'est
son choix je crois que ça a été
largement commenté mais c'est vrai que
l'actualité rattrape cette visite du
pape avec ce qui se passe à Lampedusa
avec ce qui se passe bon qui qui est
rien à côté de ce qui s'est passé depuis
que nous sommes dans cette crise
migratoire depuis la guerre en Syrie
mais bien avant là c'est spectaculaire
mais ça décrit
on a un devoir de faire cesser cette
situation aujourd'hui aussi bien pour
les pays d'immigration que pour les pays
qui reçoivent ces
clandestins la présentation du texte sur
la fin de vie a été décalé est-ce que
l'exécutif a eu raison de ne pas le
présenter la semaine de la venue du papa
Marseille pour vous vous comprenez ce
soir je sais pas si c'est un rapport
je
vois pas du tout l'intérêt de ce texte
aujourd'hui à chaque mandat s'il faut
avancer sur ce texte c'est une ligne une
urgence d'une priorité on allait la loi
Clayes léonétique dont tous les
soignants conviennent qu'elle est
suffisante maintenant c'est Emmanuel
Macron
souhaite qu'on discute de ce texte pour
qu'on ne voit pas tous les problèmes de
l'hôpital de l'accueil de l'accueil en
fin de vie je rappelle qu'il y a
plusieurs départements de mémoire c'est
une petite trentaine qui n'ont toujours
moi je crois que c'est plus de 20 plus
de 20 qui n'ont toujours pas de
donc c'est plutôt l'urgence que de que
de rediscuter de ces principes dont les
Français et les soignants
majoritairement s'accordent à dire que
ce n'est pas une priorité un dernier mot
sur votre partie les républicains qui
n'a toujours pas désigné de tête de
liste aux Européennes François-Xavier
Bellamy c'est pas évident
pour moi oui mais on verra
mais je ne sais pas de toute façon
écouter les européennes c'est dans c'est
loin maintenant et
François-Xavier Mélanie est à
remarquable député européen très
courageux très en pointe sur toutes ces
questions internationales et qui comme
ici comme Bruno Retailleau Gérard
Larcher l'ensemble des parlementaires
partage notre inquiétude notre angoisse
comme Eric Ciotti aussi sur ce qui se
passe en Arménie sur la crise des
migration quel espace vous aurez aux
européennes entre d'un côté Jordan
Bardella Marion maréchal et de l'autre
la liste de la majorité présidentielle
écoutez j'espère que la voix de ces
parlementaires qui ont fait un travail
et je parle de François-Xavier Bellamy
extraordinaire pendant tout son mandat
notamment sur toutes tes questions se
fera encore plus entendre vous savez
vous doutez de faire moins de 5% les non
moi je suis confiante parce que je pense
que les Français savent que les
solutions que proposent
les républicains aussi bien à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Sénat
notamment sur la crise migratoire sont
les seules solutions viables aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs tout le monde les reprend le
langagement de ma famille politique sur
la crise humanitaire
en Arménie est un engagement de très
longue durée et sans faille
François-Xavier brelamy pour une
Retailleau Laurent Wauquiez richioti
moi-même et plein d'autres nous sommes
rendus fréquemment sur place et nous
n'avons cessé d'être à la fois constant
et cohérent sur ces questions merci
Valérie Boyer merci beaucoup merci
arrêtez notre invité ce matin merci de
parler de ces sujets il y a encore très
peu de chaînes qui en parlent et merci
d'être venu nous en parler